the sinuses you know we hear our my
sinuses are clogged one of the most
impressive things about a skull the
sinuses are literally these little tubes
or channels through which fluid and air
can move the sinuses even though they
are essentially created by the fissures
between different bones they're actually
fairly plastic in the sense that they
can be modified in terms of their shape
and so people will say well I have a
deviated septum guess what you should
try and emphasize breathing through both
nostrils in order to UND deviate your
septum now if someone has a broken nose
or something that's really structurally
abnormal they may need corrective
surgery but purely through deliberate
nasal breathing so it could be mouth
taping at night but also just
deliberately nasal breathing during most
of your cardiovascular training unless
you need to really you know hit the gas
in which case mouth breathe is going to
help dilate the sinuses and lead to
better air flow which makes nasal
breathing easier